Okay.
Good morning.
Um,
one prefatory point before we get into today's lecture,
uh,
that's occasion by having you read Macintyre,
but I ought really to have mentioned it before.
Um,
Mcintyre's book after virtue is in part a conversation with major figures in the
tradition,
uh,
who you have not read or at least not in the scores a Aquinas Niche,
um,
Hagle and many others.
And of course this came up with John Roles in that,
uh,
and indeed Robert Nozick,
both of whom depended on arguments from Emmanuel Kant that we haven't studied in
this course either.
And so one question that arises as well,
to what extent are you responsible for,
uh,
there for understanding the people on whom they are commenting and of course
you're entering in a car into a canvas and ongoing conversation among these
thinkers that's been going on for centuries and to some degree you just have to
jump in somewhere.
Nonetheless,
for the purposes of our course here,
you're certainly not responsible for understanding cons,
ethics,
and indeed we could,
I could give several lectures on why it,
why it is the case that con would not have agreed either with rolls,
his interpretation of his own work or with the roles in enterprise,
but,
um,
we're not really interested in con in this course,
but in roles in that instance.
So to the extent he depends upon a faulty reading of cons,
um,
groundwork of the metaphysics of morals.
That's not a question with which we are engaged in this course.
Uh,
it's not that we're taking a position about it,
we're just agnostic.
Likewise with the various,
uh,
think is that McEntire engages,
um,
you are not expected to know a saint benedict or neat show or at Aquinas or
anybody else or indeed,
Aristotle about whom I have quite a bit to say today.
Um,
except in so far as they are,
they are building blocks for Macintyre's argument.
So Mcintyre's work in some ways is a commentary on the history of ideas,
but really it's first and foremost and argument and we're interested in it as an
argument and that's how we're going to evaluate it.
So,
um,
of course it's an invitation to you later on to go into some of these thinkers
in depth with whom he is engaged and see where the ultimately you agree or
disagree with the way in which he had engages those thinkers.
But that's not our agenda here.
Our agenda here is to think of Allister Mcintyre as somebody who's making an
argument in his own right and that's how we're going to engage with his work.
He is a political theorist who,
um,
currently teaches at Notre Dame.
Um,
interestingly,
um,
they say that the hand that rocks the cradle controls the person forever.
I,
after he started out,
uh,
I think he was raised in a Catholic.
Uh,
he had a catholic upbringing,
but early on in his career,
he must be well into his eighties.
Now,
early on in his Korea,
he wrote a book called Marxism and Christianity.
And he was clearly wrestling with,
you know,
who wins out of out of,
uh,
Mark's and Christianity.
And in that book he concluded that Marxism One,
and in his early incarnations he was a fairly conventional Marxist,
but then gradually he came full circle,
um,
and ended up rejecting not only Marxism but the larger enlightenment project of
which Marxism as you all know is only one part a and ended up affirming a kind
of,
um,
traditional,
mix of Aristotelian ism and the Catholic tradition.
Um,
that informs his argument both in after virtue.
And then a subsequent book,
which I'm not having you read,
uh,
I called who's tradition,
which rationality.
So he is somebody who in in an important sense has come full circle.
Um,
and I think that it's war that's an important piece of background to know in
understanding his work off the virtue he's written on.
He's written many other books too,
but this is the book for which he will be remembered.
You might think it odd that a book with a title like that could have become a
best seller,
but it really was a philosophical bestseller when it was published,
I believe in 1984 a and the addition you have,
um,
includes an off the word where he responds to critics of the original book.
So
how,
who is Alister Mcintyre and how does he relate to the,
the historical Auntie enlightenment?
Think as we've already discussed,
namely,
um,
Burke and Devlin.
Well,
uh,
he is very much in the spirit of the tradition in which they both wrote.
Although as you could probably guess from his historical trajectory,
one thing that differentiates Sam is that at least for much of his life,
he thought of himself as somebody on the political left,
whereas they were people on the political right.
And we'll come back to the significance of that later.
He is part of a general,
uh,
I'm toe or reaction against the Rawlsian enterprise in political theory.
Uh,
other thinkers,
uh,
which you are not waiting,
but with whom he would naturally have some elective affinities are the
philosopher Richard Rorty,
who died recently,
who wrote a fabulously good book called philosophy and the Mirror of nature,
which was a critique of the enlightenment project in philosophy.
Um,
arguing roadies argument was basically that the,
the enlightenment quest for certainty was a fool's errand.
That there is no such thing as certainty to be had.
We've discussed this quite extensively,
of course,
in connection with the early versus late enlightenment,
which is not a distinction Richard Rorty made,
but India,
in any event,
he,
he made the argument that the,
the enlightenment quest for certainty was a fool's errand,
begun basically by Descartes and,
uh,
taken to its apotheosis in cons critique of pure reason,
and that,
that the desc philosophers from Descartes to Kant got engaged in this hopeless
endeavor of justifying philosophy from the ground up,
from into biteable premises.
And when they failed to do that,
they thought that,
uh,
some important philosophical,
failure had occurred.
Whereas Rorty,
his point was they should never be an engaged in that enterprise.
To begin with.
And he connects importantly to the modern pragmatists tradition of Dewey and
purse and James,
uh,
and to the postmodernist thinkers like,
[inaudible],
um,
to stomach sent Michel Foucault and others that we don't have time to read in
this course.
So roared ea is an Auntie Maude and us,
but he's a postmodernist anti modernist.
If you want lots of jargon,
he's thinks we should get beyond the enlightenment project.
He has also written some about politics.
Um,
and indeed he has a political analog of his philosophical argument,
which is,
is,
uh,
the bumper sticker version of it is that I'm thinking we have to justify our
political institutions from the ground up is also a Mug's game and indeed a
dangerous mug's game.
Because when we fail to do that,
we start to think that there's something with our political institutions that
they're illegitimate because we couldn't justify them from the ground up
successfully by the terms of the enlightenment project.
Therefore,
they're not justifiable.
And this Rorty thanks puts us at a competitive disadvantage,
but he was writing during the Cold War.
So with,
uh,
our antagonists,
behind the iron curtain,
but I think he would make the same argument were he alive today about a
fundamentalist antagonists who,
uh,
we would buy roadies way of thinking it'd be putting ourselves at a competitive
disadvantage with,
by holding ourselves and our institutions to a standard which cannot be met.
And then when we fail to meet it,
losing confidence in our institutions.
So we could have read Richard Rorty in this course,
but he's,
the truth is,
and you know,
this is a dogmatic statement and maybe some of you will second guessed me on it
later.
The truth is,
Rorty is a much better philosophy then he is a political theorist.
And so we've,
I've chosen to have you read,
uh,
Mcintyre,
who I think it's a better political theorist than he is a philosopher.
There are others.
Uh,
perhaps one of the most famous is Michael Walzer,
the who wrote a book called Spears of justice,
who also rejects the idea that the values guiding politics can be justified in a
logical sense from intubate or for India biteable first premises and generate,
um,
guides for action in politics that,
uh,
must be compelling to any right thinking,
rational person.
All of these thinkers,
Rorty walls,
a McIntyre,
um,
sometimes get grouped under this idea of communitarianism communitarianism and
communitarianism is linked to the anti enlightenment endeavor in that it is the,
the a historical version of tradition that is instead of with Burke and um,
Devlin appealing to tradition as the basis for our values.
Communitarians Purdue appeal to the community accepted values as the basis for
what should guide us.
Now,
obviously the two things are connected and we'll see they're deeply connected
in,
in Mcintyre's a historical account because communities are shaped by traditions.
Um,
but at the end of the day,
what's going to be important for us is that the individual is subservient to the
community rather than the community being that creek creature or the creation of
the individual.
So the community comes first,
the individuals born into the community rather than the community being that the
product of some contract or creation or construction of the individual.
Okay.
So that's what all of these thinkers share in common.
Now,
one of the things that makes Macintyre's book a little bit difficult to read is
it's a work in the history of ideas that's written backwards.
Um,
that is,
he starts with the present and works back to the ancients.
Uh,
it's a very
interesting thing to do.
I expect,
I once taught the,
uh,
the political science one 14 course,
the intro to the history of ideas.
And I,
it partly inspired by Macintyre effort.
I did it backwards.
I went from roles to Plato and that there are interesting pedagogical,
uh,
challenges there.
And I'm not sure whether it's worth doing just for its own sake,
but macintyre does it for a reason.
I'm not just to be cute,
which I think maybe I was trying to do.
Um,
Mcintyre's does it for a reason and his reason is that he thinks that at
sometime around the beginning of the enlightenment,
the western intellectual project went badly off the rails.
And,
um,
in some way his argument is an analog of the argument I made to you about lock,
uh,
and workmanship.
Because off row,
think about the,
what I said about lock and workmanship.
I said there was a,
basically a coherent story.
You know,
God created the world.
He has workman,
shipped a knowledge and writes over it.
He creates humans with the capacity to act in a godlike fashion,
miniature gods,
although that constrained by God's swell and it all fits together as a kind of
coherent hole once you buy into the premises in all fits together.
But then what happens in,
in the history of,
uh,
the workmanship model is people start to secularize it.
And so start taking on bits and pieces of the original workmanship idea without
the unifying a assumptions that gave that model.
It's coherence.
And we saw the various difficulties everybody ran into,
uh,
in doing that marks and Nozick and roles and many others.
Uh,
so Macintyre's does something analogous in his book.
What he wants to say is that the task of coming up with compelling moral values
to guide politics made sense in a frame of framework of assumptions that we
inherited.
But we inherited in a kind of,
um,
degraded way that the unifying assumptions that used to give political morality,
it's coherence have been jettisoned as a byproduct of the enlightenment project.
And for that reason,
we need to go back in time and see where the project went off the rails,
see what it was that happened that caused modern thinkers to get involved in
this fool's errand of justifying morality from the ground up.
Uh,
justifying from morality,
from the ground up,
cannot be done because of the expectations about justification that we have
developed.
But,
but Macintyre's claim is you can't see that unless you go backwards in time to
understand how and where the project went off the rails.
So that's the big enterprise of his book and will mostly get into that big
enterprise on Wednesday.
But I want to focus at the,
at,
at the start on the beginning of his book and it's the beginning of his book
deals with the symptoms of our problem.
And once one,
perhaps the most important symptom of our problem,
you've already confronted in this course when we talked about the transition
from classical to neoclassical utilitarianism and the rise of emotive as call
Stevenson and all that.
Anyone remember,
maybe have already forgotten all of this was so long ago.
Now remember Stevenson said,
this is the guy who didn't get tenure in the Yale philosophy department because
he seemed to have this extreme relativistic and subjectivist view of ethics
where moral choices were just differences in taste,
differences in flavors of ice cream use.
You say,
you know,
um,
the welfare state is good.
I say the welfare state is bad.
It's just like saying,
uh,
chocolate ice cream is good.
Uh,
or you know,
strawberry ice cream is good.
That differences about morality,
uh,
adjust merely subjective differences.
So it's uh,
you know,
we go from this,
um,
certainty,
uh,
subjective certainty and the early enlightenment is being making politics like
mathematical Gr,
gr geometric proofs for Hobbes and Locke to the mere subjectivism of the mature
enlightenment,
which produces this kind of relativistic morality where everything is just
subjective opinion,
that morality is nothing more than emotion.
And,
um,
there's no particular reason even to think we have the same emotions.
Remember that as I think I said to you at the time,
Stevenson was criticizing,
uh,
David Hume,
who was another important,
a utilitarian thinker who we didn't have time to read in the scores either,
but you should all read at some point,
uh,
in your lives and human said,
well,
yes,
you can't get,
you can't get any important statements about what ought to be the case from
empirical statements about the world.
There's no way to get from is two ort,
as Jim said.
But you know what?
Most people are pretty much alike.
Most people are pretty much the same.
So we can,
to use the jargon of a utilitarianism,
we can make it pretty confident interpersonal judgments about people.
People are pretty similar.
And so what's good for one person is likely to be good for another.
And that's why,
uh,
Hume has this rare,
the cryptic one liner that scholars have debated to the effect that if all
factual questions were resolved,
no moral questions would remain.
It's this notion what people are pretty much the same.
Uh,
and so even though a morality is rooted in people's emotional reactions to
situations,
um,
it's not a big problem to having a morality that can form the basis of a
society.
Stevenson said,
how do you know,
how do you know how to you David Hume?
Now maybe,
um,
you know,
add off.
Eichmann has one set of emotional reactions to the prospect of shipping people
off to concentration camps.
And you and I have a different set of emotional reactions to shipping people off
to concentration camps.
And if you're saying there are no principles by which we can adjudicate among
those reactions,
those emotional reactions,
you throwing us into a sea of relativism.
And so,
um,
when you get too emotive ism,
you're getting to this world in which we are completely without instruments,
for making moral judgments.
When people disagree,
that is the emotive just culture.
It's a culture of tastes and not interpersonal judgments.
And one of the things Mcintyre wants to say is that all of this becomes
inevitable in the 17th century.
It's just a question of time.
Uh,
once you look at what was really going on in the beginning of the enlightenment,
you're going to wind up with a motive isn't just a question of time.
And the politics that comes out of it is pretty ugly,
right?
The politics that comes out of it,
uh,
basically leaves you without standards of moral judgment and indeed without
questioning the raw assertion of power.
So it's not only that philosophy,
we wind up with emotive as him,
but in politics,
we're ultimately going to wind up with nature.
We're going to wind up with kind of knee her list assertion of the
inevitability of the triumph of the will,
the triumph of power.
So,
um,
again,
nature.
Somebody else I wish we had time to talk about in this course,
but you'll have to read him for,
for our purposes through the eyes of Mcintyre.
So it all goes bad around the late 16th,
early 17th century and then we're just rolling down this hill into um,
the best of modern subjectivism in philosophy and uh,
neolistic politics.
Um,
pretty depressing story.
You might think.
So that's one symptom that we live in.
This what Macintyre wants to describe as an emotive vest culture.
Another symptom of it which you might not find as um,
this spirit
as what I've just said is what we,
this isn't mackintosh terminology,
but I think it makes the point it's a world in which instrumentalism has
triumphed a world in which there has been a total separation between means and
ends.
One symptom of this,
again,
not one he mentions in his book,
but I think a captures neatly what he's talking about is
the proliferation of business schools.
A hundred years ago there was no such thing as a business goal in a university.
Nobody had ever thought of the idea of even having a business school.
And what's I think note about,
about business schools is that they're teaching skills that are unrelated to
purposes.
So
business schools after all
are trying to teach people how to become good managers.
Where are they going to manage the Coca Cola Corporation or whether you're going
to manage,
um,
Goldman Sachs or where you're going to manage a university.
The assumption is there a certain kinds of skills that managers have that it's
important to know,
but business goals will not teach you whether it's a good idea.
Tim Managed Coca Cola or Goldman Sachs or Yale University.
That is not what business schools are about,
right?
So business goals,
if you like,
are predicated on the divorcing of means from an they turned teaching certain
kinds of instrumental skills
that you can find helpful regardless
of what your,
what the enterprise is,
you're gonna end up managing
being a good manager is being somebody who is inherently an instrumental person.
Right.
And,
um,
of course that leaves on answered the question well,
but shouldn't we attend to what it is we are managing after all?
That was a question that came up in our very first lecture in this course when
we talked about the Eifman problem,
right?
That he didn't care he wanted to do while he wanted to impress a superior as he
wanted to get an a,
he was happy shipping Jews around the Third Reich to concentration camps as well
as he could,
but he would have been equally happy shipping munitions parts or,
or for that matter,
you know,
office supplies.
It wasn't important as far as he was concerned.
He wanted to be a good manager.
So this is a very 20th century kind of preoccupation that we put the goal,
the purpose,
the ultimate endeavor aside.
And we say,
what are the characteristics of being an effective manager?
Right?
It's to use the philosophical jargon.
Um,
it is an a radically Auntie teleological.
You right?
Teleology,
teleological.
We talked and I told you why Taylor,
what is teleological mean?
Somebody,
right?
Tell us.
Comes from the Greek word.
Tell also purpose.
Goal director.
Right?
Mcentire thinks that the rejection of teleology is a huge problematic,
enduring mistake.
Okay.
And I'm going to come back to why in a,
in a few minutes,
but first I want to return to the first symptom I mentioned about time.
So these two symptoms,
the rise of subjectivism and emotive as and the knee,
holistic kinds of politics that brings with it on the one hand.
And secondly,
this rejection of teleology on the other hand.
And then say a little bit more about each of them.
Neither of them is what it's seen,
says Mcintyre.
Who knows what the TV program that used to be on CNN for a long time called
crossfire.
Was Anybody?
Anyone have a seat crossfire on CNN?
Yeah.
Tell us how it works like that.
Take the microphone and tell us how it works.
How did it work?
Anyone?
You might be too young.
It's kind of sad.
Yeah.
Some of you might not be quite too young.
How did it work?
I think it was like a point.
Counterpoint.
Yeah.
So how to change.
What's that?
Yeah.
So I'm not sure going into it whether you knew,
what should I do?
You've definitely had to known which side you were debating or no,
do they just kind of give it to you?
And then you either debated for or against a certain thing and then there was a
judge at the end to decide who the winner was
basically.
Uh,
except for your last point,
there was no winner.
I'll come back to that.
But basically you've got it right.
The idea was they have a left wing host and a right wing house.
So they would have,
you know,
Robert Novak as the right wing host.
Then Michael Kinsley say somebody like that as the left wing host.
Um,
and there would be some topic,
do juror,
you know,
whether it was partial birth abortion or whatever,
the,
whatever it was,
the ta affirmative action.
Um,
uh,
and what would happen was,
they would then usually have two guests and the guests were chosen also to be
sort of ideologically different.
Right.
And the,
the Novak type person would fire questions at the left wing guests and the
Kinsey LivePerson would fire questions to the right wing guests and they would
argue back and forth and it would get more and more valuable,
uh,
and,
and impassioned,
you know,
the,
and then at two minutes to eight,
that commercial would come on and they would add.
Okay.
And,
um,
why do I bring this up?
I bring this up because of,
okay.
Mcintyre's observation right at the beginning of the book where he says,
this is certain odd feature tomorrow argument in this emotive it's world,
there's a strange feature.
On the one hand,
it's subjectivist.
Okay.
In all the ways we've talked about everybody's views equal to everybody else's,
we can't,
was no authoritative figure,
right?
There's no authoritative figure to settle our disagreements,
at least not an earthly one.
And everybody is what they are and who they are.
And that's that.
On the other hand,
McEntire says,
if you look at things like abortion or affirmative action or nuclear weapons,
people argue about these questions as though they were a right answer.
Okay?
They give reasons for their views.
They tried to shut the other side's being hypocritical.
They say they want to say,
my premises are more plausible than your premises.
They argue with each other as though there were an answer to this question,
should we opt la law abortion,
we should we add more partial birth abortion.
The arguments they get into suggests they,
that everybody's assuming there is an answer to that question.
Right,
but actually nobody expects the question to be resolved.
And I thought that's why I mentioned the crossfire,
because you know what could never have happened on that TV show is sort of
okay,
you know,
at seven 46 Michael Kinsley turning to Novak and saying,
hmm,
no,
I never thought of that.
Actually.
Maybe you're right.
That was the,
the the,
if they did that,
first of all,
the sponsors would pull,
pull their commercials,
Kinsley would be fired.
But that's not what it's about.
That's not what's some,
but then,
but then it's bizarre isn't it?
Because if everybody agrees that we're all subjectivists right and that all our
views are equally a tenable or untenable,
which they seem to right,
then why is everybody going through the motions of arguing like this?
Why is everybody saying,
you know what?
I make any sense and this is misuse of evidence in your blah,
blah,
and look my arguments much stronger and blah.
Why would anybody bother if we really believed the suggests this objectivism,
which we seem to take for granted.
Okay.
That for Mcintyre is the real symptom
of what's wrong without circumstances.
The fact that we engage in interminable moral arguments that we do not expect to
be able to resolve is the symptom of the malady of our time in his view.
Because it suggests a kind of thirst
and a set of expectations from the past.
He wants to say that we need to be able to recover because,
okay.
The fact that we carry on arguing suggests we don't want to accept this emotive
as culture.
We're not comfortable with it.
It's not emotionally,
morally,
psychologically,
philosophically satisfying to us.
Not even acceptable.
MMM.
But,
so he thinks one of the things we need to be able to do
is account for this puzzle,
this puzzle that we engage in.
Moral argument,
okay?
Using the forms of persuasive reasoning that we don't actually expect to
resolve.
So that po moral argument has this quality of,
of crossfire,
right?
So that's,
that's the one thing that we need
to get some kind of grip on if we're going to understand what's wrong with a
motive as culture.
The second is this problem with teleology.
It they turn out to be related.
But here's the problem with rejecting teleology,
okay?
If I walked in here,
if I walked in here one morning and got up on this stage and I said to you,
well,
this morning I got up,
got dressed,
went for a run,
came back,
took a shower,
I got dressed again,
started walking down to the office and I cross down to Orange Street.
And then I cross Scana street.
I,
uh,
got down to Whitney at some point,
pretty soon you'd say,
what is the point of this?
Why is he telling us this?
Human beings always wanna know the purpose.
What is the point?
So
we will never be satisfied with any activity that is point less,
that doesn't have a point.
And the enlightenment and Devaa off.
Trying to be agnostic about purposes
and scientific about means is never going to be satisfying to us for that
reason.
People want to know the point.
They want to believe their existence has have a point.
And um,
if they don't,
they become disaffected board agitated,
I'm happy or worse.
MMM.
One he McEntire ash has a brilliant little essay called epistemological crises
and dramatic narratives where he,
he points out that,
um,
if a little,
if a young child asks you why the Earth doesn't fall down,
you tell them,
say a story that it's being held up by a giant.
That's why giants holding the earth in his hands.
That's why it doesn't fall down.
That's adequate for awhile.
Right.
And then they asked for another story when they stop believing in giants,
but he's,
he's claim is it something about the structure of human psychology that even,
you know,
explanations rooted in physics ultimately take the form of narratives.
People want to be able to tell a story that we fit into that has some point or
purpose that we,
our basic understanding of the world as is as teleological purpose of creatures
who tell narratives to give point to their existence and we're going to become
uncomfortable
if we don't have a way of understanding politics that has a point.
So that is the,
that is the symptom of how about
plight that we live in this emotive as well that we can accept and we have this
bizarre love hate relationship with it.
When you look at the kinds of moral arguments we actually engage in.
And secondly,
we live in this world in which we've tried to cope with the deep pluralism.
Rawls writes about by taking goals off the table purposes off the table,
right?
And seeing can we just be a instrumental.
So if you want another political theorists,
we don't have time to read but has a good one liner to capture what Macintyre
thinks is the problem.
It's Russo's line in the first paragraph of the social contract where he says
he's going to come up with a design of institutions for society taking men as
they are and laws as they might be taking men as they are and laws as they might
be.
And the reason Macintyre would think that problematic is taking men as they are
men and women,
we might say today as they are
okay.
Ignores important questions about how they have come to be as they are and what
the role of morality is in shaping and reshaping human nature.
So the title of the book is after Virtue
and virtue,
so-called what modern political model in philosophers call virtue ethics come
out of a different tradition than anything we've considered thus far in this
course.
Namely the Aristotelian tradition.
Right?
Aristotle was the person who talked about the virtues.
Right.
And,
um,
what Macintyre wants to say is we are,
yeah.
At some important level that we don't fully appreciate or understand products or
the inheritors of
okay.
Uh,
kind of degraded Aristotelian tradition.
We have taken over concepts and categories with thinking about ethics from the
Aristotelian tradition.
Okay.
But in a way that has become degraded in a way that abandoned the most important
assumptions behind the Aristotelian tradition that make it all hang together.
And the two key notions,
okay,
the two analytical devices that make this argument work are what he calls a
practice and a virtue practice comes first.
And I'll say a little bit about that and then I'll say a little bit about
virtues and then we'll go into his argument in more detail on Wednesday a
practice.
He says,
yeah,
any coherent and complex form of socially established cooperative human activity
through which goods internal to that activity are realized,
not an engaging sentence.
Let me try and give it content for you.
So first of all,
the idea of a practice,
this is the intuition
when you walk into a class at Yale where the first time,
say as a freshman,
okay,
think about what you don't do.
You don't say to yourself,
how should this class be run?
Let's see if we shall we.
You don't immediately interrupt other people and say,
let's all decide how to run this class.
Let's shall we vote on it?
It was,
shall we talk about it?
That's not what you do,
right?
When you walk into your first yell class as a freshman,
you sit down,
you look around,
you say,
what's going on here?
What are the norms?
What's expected of me?
What am I suppose to do?
That's what you say to yourself.
So right there,
McEntire wants to say that the social contract metaphor is really bad.
The misleading of the human experience because people don't create Tabula Rasa.
Rare that people are born into practices that they inherit from the past and
reproduce into the future.
A practice is,
it's,
it's complicated.
It's already socially established,
it's ongoing.
When you discovered people have been teaching courses at Yale for centuries and
they've been freshmen who have walked into them and saying,
what do I do now?
What's expected of me?
Right?
So the,
the,
the point is that the practice precedes the participants,
not the other way around.
Right?
So that's the first idea at coherent and,
and complex.
It's,
it's coherent in that it has some goal,
purpose,
right?
Um,
enlightenment.
Let's say it's the purpose in this course,
not in the sense of they enlightenment but enlightening you,
right?
Um,
socially established.
It's cooperative that everybody,
uh,
he wants to say practices are not coercive.
We'll come back to that later.
Let's go APP operative.
Um,
human activity through which goods internal to that activity are realized.
So that's an important term.
Internal.
And here he has in mind,
let's suppose,
let's suppose you're playing chess.
Okay,
you're paying chess with me and I,
I have to go and answer the phone in the middle of the game.
And while I'm,
while I'm not in the room,
you take one of my points off the board,
come back and you win.
That's not playing by the rules.
That's not an internal realization of a good,
that's,
that's what we would call an in his terminology,
external.
Right?
So the idea of a practice is there are rules constituting the practice by which
you have to excel.
Okay.
Right?
So you have to learn the rules,
right?
Cheating doesn't count,
So that's the notion of a practice.
I'll go into it in more detail.
Okay.
Virtues are what gift practices their point virtues have to do with the goals
imminent in practices.
He says a virtue is an acquired human quality,
the possession and exercise of which tends to enable us to achieve those goods,
which are internal to practices and the lack of which effectively prevents us
from achieving any such goods.
So
what human beings want,
I'll leave you with this thought and we'll pick up from it on Wednesday.
What human beings want is to excel internally in practices.
Says Macintyre,
you've all heard the phrase,
he's a pitcher's Pitcher,
right?
When we say he's a pitcher's pitcher,
what are,
what we have in mind is the notion that uh,
he's,
he is so skilled
that only a true pro can appreciate how skilled he really is.
Right?
So if I write books and I also build sheds,
okay,
right.
If I show my books to people who know how to build sheds and they say,
oh yeah,
really good book,
and I show my carpentry to a bunch of nerdy academics and they say,
oh,
that's really good.
That's not going to be satisfying to me because what I really want,
I want to be a pitcher's pitcher.
I want people who know about books to be impressed with my books and I want
people know about carpentry to being pressed by my shed.
So that's the notion of,
of internal goods that every practice has goods by reference to which you excel
within that practice.
You don't want to win a chess by stealing the porn when a person's not looking,
you want to beat them.
Uh,
in terms of the norms and rules of playing good chess.
So the,
the notion is,
uh,
you know,
you walk into the classroom,
you want to get an Aa,
but not by downloading a paper off the internet.
You want to get the a,
uh,
by reference to the norms and practices governing what goes on in the classroom.
So that's the basic idea of virtues being internal to practices and giving them
their point and anti wants to say that this,
these two terms,
these practices and virtue capture a lot more that is relevant about human
psychology.
Then the assumptions that drove the enlightenment,
and we'll start with that on Wednesday.